à venir par les sides usage veut dire
parler beaucoup de productivité parce
que c'est un smartphone qui est dédié à
la productivité et notamment grâce à ce
que vous avez dans cet étui là c'est à
dire un espen folle d'edition le samsung
galaxy fold n'est pas seulement un
smartphone qui se plie 6 7 ans matricule
c'est pas seulement un smartphone qui
explique c'est une ouverture sur le
monde dans la productivité c'est
peut-être la fin de la gamme note de
samsung allez savoir en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que ce smartphone là il ne
laisse pas indifférent c'est peut-être
l'avenir du smartphone en tout cas ça me
semble le laisser entre apercevoir le
tarif aujourd'hui reste quand même
relativement élevé 1799 euros sur la
version 256 go de stockage et
1899 euros sur la version 512 ya de
stockage néanmoins à ce tarif là vous
avez en tout est très atypique qui est
vraiment intéressant et notamment pour
la productivité mais s'en va le regarder
mais vous allez voir il n'y a pas que ça
comme usages et ce smartphone au delà de
la productivité il a fait de belles
promesses il est donc temps aujourd'hui
de vous donner mon retour ça fait
plusieurs jours que j'utilise carte sim
à l'intérieur et vous allez voir vous
allez voir que sept mètres là elle est
extrêmement intéressante
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
2021 est une année charnière pour
samsung ils ont absolument sortie aucune
gamme note la gamme note c'était la
gueule avec le stylet souvenez vous
c'est un espèce de gros s20 améliorer
accès productivité avec un respect d'un
style équidés seront j'ai directement à
l'intérieur on a vu arriver il ya
quelques années les airs jester le style
est connecté en bluetooth qui apportait
de nouvelles fonctionnalités sauf que
cette année ils ont décidé de ne pas
sortir cette gamme note mon avis la
gamme golf n'est pas forcément la gamme
qui se vendait plus aujourd'hui il ya un
changement un peu des gammes on a vu
arriver le s pen souvenez vous début
2021 sur le samsung galaxy s 21 ultra le
plus gros modèle vous pouvez avoir un
stylet sans les aides geyster et si on
voit arriver sur un nouveau samsung
galaxy z fold trois êtres folle de 3
j'oublie des fois le z j'oublie des fois
le galaxy c'est le nom exact samsung
galaxy z folle de 3 eh bien on voit
arriver un espen en réalité on varie les
deux espèces ça c'est le s pen folle
d'edition il est à 49 euros mais vous
avez également le s pen pro 99 euros qui
se connectera en bluetooth que voulait
pour venir utiliser sur différents
appareils des tablettes votre êtes folle
de 3 et notamment le samsung galaxy s 21
ultra mais celui-là le foll l'edition il
est là pour le foll que pour le foll et
il apporte pas mal d'usagers on va me
dire deux types d' usage principaux le
premier s'avère sans le respect tu sens
le semaine parce que oui effectivement
et bien ce samsung galaxy z folle de 3
même s'il est très atypique restant
smartphones la taille des écrans ne
change pas par rapport à ce qu'on avait
sur le galaxy cette folle de deux
intérieurs extérieurs c'est la même
chose par contre on se retrouve son
dynamique amoled 2 x qui est un vrai
gain est un vrai gap et le gain principe
à quoi me retrouver ici c'est d'avoir un
taux de rafraîchissement de 120 hertz à
l'extérieur mais également à l'intérieur
alors ce taux de rafraîchissement de 120
hertz il va vraiment revenir à portée
lorsque vous allez venir scrollé
principalement sa portrait de la
fluidité ça va être bien meilleur pour
votre oeil et ça viendra vraiment
augmenter l'expérience et notamment
également pour des parties de gaming
donc si vous êtes joueur ça veut dire
mettre les belles un peu plus haut pour
regarder des films pour autant vous
n'avez pas besoin vous restez en 60 r ça
ira très très bien vous êtes d'un
système adaptatif un système intelligent
à l'intérieur qui va faire le switch
automatiquement alors on pourrait se
dire est ce que ce sens vers va venir
consommer davantage fatalement oui mais
pour autant je n'ai pas senti réellement
différence par rapport aux est folle de
deux jo reste sur une autonomie de un
jour et demi ça me convient en tout cas
par rapport à ce que j'attends d'un
smartphone comme celui là j'utilise
comme j'utiliserai n'importe quel
smartphone des réseaux sociaux dus
avertissements des emails des sms des
appels du web sap bref un usage complet
et cohérent lusage écran extérieur écran
intérieures jai pas voulu reprendre on
l'a déjà vu avec le galaxy z folle de 2
par contre pour tout ce qui va être
visionnage films séries c'est un vrai
confort on n'est plus réellement dans la
productivité on n'est plus dans le
divertissement mais malgré tout c'est un
usage fort de ce smartphone mis en avant
par samsung est une nouveauté cette
année et qui est vraiment intéressante
c'est la caméra intégrée sous l'écran et
la caméra intégrée sous l'écran je
l'attendais depuis un petit moment chez
samsung elle est planqué juste là là ici
alors autant on la verra sur un fond
blanc savait qu'elle va sortir un
avantage autant lorsque vous allez
regarder un film une série eh bien ça se
fait oublier alors je veux revenir un
petit peu sur ce que je vous ai dit dans
la présentation je reste un peu sur ma
faim maison c'est bien cette caméra sous
l'écran j'attendais depuis le début chez
samsung j'avais déjà vu ailleurs et elle
a mis un petit peu de temps à arriver
elle est arrivée elle est enfin là donc
elle va probablement soutenir se
démocratiser en 2022 on le retrouvera
probablement dans la gamme s pourquoi
pas au niveau du reste 22 ça on le verra
l'année prochaine donc abonnez-vous dès
maintenant pour être tenu informé
lorsque vous regardez des films des
séries la caméra se fait totalement
oublié par rapport à ce qu'on avait
l'année dernière avec un petit point ce
manque un vrai bénéfice et c'est super
intéressant pour autant c'est vrai qu'on
le voit encore un petit peu c'est pas
parfait mais c'est quand même vachement
bien c'est vachement mieux par rapport à
ce qu'on avait avant donc bravo samsung
merci pour l'évolution et j'espère que
peut-être l'année prochaine la
technologie évoluant la caméra sera
totalement invisible ou en tout cas on
ne verra pas le petit rond avec les
quelques petites piques celles qui
viennent par dessus le petit bémol qu'on
va avoir c'est comme on est sur un
format qui n'est pas un format 16 9ème
et bien lorsque vous allez venir
regarder des films des séries vous allez
avoir des grandes bandes en haut et en
bas lorsque vous venez vous met dans
l'image pour remplir toute la partie de
votre écran eh bien on perd du contenu
on en perd un petit peu trop alors moi
je regarde des films là dessus mais je
les regarde vraiment en 16/9 je cherche
pas où mais vu la taille de l'écran que
vous avez là je vous assure ça pose
absolument aucun problème et le confort
et la le confort visionnage reste malgré
tout ici après il ya un truc est super
intéressant qu'on va retrouver non pas
sur netflix mais sur youtube c'est ce
qu'on appellera le flex mode alors ce
flex mode il est intéressant c'est que
vous prenez votre smartphone voulu plier
sur la partie du haut vous avez votre
vidéo là pour le coup le ratio vient
vraiment beaucoup plus intéressant et
pour regarder monsieur par exemple
pourquoi pas sur youtube eh ben il ya un
vrai confort et ça c'est vraiment bien
donc ce flex mode il est bien pensée et
vous permet de mettre en bas un chat d
email vous pouvez travailler
alors vous me direz vous quel est
l'intérêt de dire regardez monsieur gros
travail on est bien j'en sais rien voilà
si vous avez envie de prendre des notes
en tout cas vous pouvez le faire et
c'est avec un grand plaisir à déjouer
également termes de productivité vous
mettez une vidéo sur youtube qui vous
servira pour le travail pourquoi pas et
bien en bas vous pouvez faire de la
prise de notes avec la suite office
microsoft ou pourquoi pas un tableur
excel il ya beaucoup de possibilités et
c'est vraiment l'intérêt du multitâche
aujourd'hui ici alors puisqu'on parle du
multitâche on va y rester parce que
c'est vraiment l'idée de cet écran je
vous le dis directement je suis pas un
utilisateur de multitâche c'est pas mon
dada il y en a plein qui le sont et
j'arrive à comprendre cet usage là ici
vous pouvez venir m en tout 3
applications en même temps 3 vous pouvez
sans problème vous avez commencé un peu
à un enquête place par endroit et vous
pouvez venir ajouter des fenêtre
flottante sur le dessus quelques unes au
bout d'un moment ça devient un petit peu
imbitable et pas forcément très pratique
mais après vous réduisez vos fenêtres et
vos fenêtres flottant employés elles
viennent se positionner là vous pouvez
venir les déplacez vous cliquez dessus
pour ouvrir enfin bref tout est
extrêmement pratique et ça c'est grâce à
wendake c'est vrai quoi nous lie c'est
une super expérience logiciel j'en ai
déjà parlé là elle est vraiment adapté à
un smartphone qui explique donc samsung
a vraiment également très très très bien
travaillé ce côté là donc l'expérience
logiciel est adapté il est absolument
aucune fausse note là où ce smartphone à
vraiment prendre toute sa dimension
productivité vous en douterez c'est avec
ça alors le s pen en poste de kyle en
coin de l'oreille l'onea d'un architecte
en train de réfléchir à sa prochaine
création mais le mieux quand même c'est
le promu dans la main alors ce espagne
il est vachement bien il est vachement
bien pourquoi parceque il permet à ce
smartphone qui quand même un certain
prix est bien devenir vraiment bragg et
les professionnels on est à quasiment
1800 euros sur la version de base c'est
un smartphone qui coûte très cher mais
c'est pas n'importe quel smartphone
c'est de l'innovation c'est de
l'ingénierie il ya un côté très malin
extrêmement pratique et sûr ça normal
qu'il ait rendu compatible avec un espen
si vous êtes vraiment axé productivité
pour moi venez prendre le espagne en
complément 49 euros je suis d'accord ça
fait rajouter le blog de charge le spn
quand on a dépensé 1799 euros c'est ce
serait quand même dommage de passer à
côté de ça alors on pourrait se dire
samsung pour nous l'offrir avec ouais
c'est pas le cas la bonne nouvelle c'est
qu'à une offre de lancement jusqu'au 31
octobre 2021 150 euros remboursés sur un
ou plusieurs accessoires vous permettra
notamment de vous offrir un espère donc
ça c'est la bonne nouvelle pour tout
savoir le lien est en bas dans la
description alors ceux qui espèrent
obtenir le ranger dans un étui en
étudier aussi très très cool garder un
plat je le prends je glisse ces
pratiques alors le truc que je vais un
peu venir regretté j'allais beaucoup
avec la gamme note est bien c'est que
l'espagne vous veniez le mettre
directement dans votre smartphone ici
vous en douterez pour essayer de le
mettre il va rentrer nulle part ici on
peut pas venir utiliser son espagne avec
son écran extérieur uniquement avec son
écran intérieur alors je dis uniquement
mais c'est déjà bien et c'est déjà
beaucoup on peut venir faire tout ce que
vous faisiez avec un samsung galaxy note
qu'on peut bien le faire ici avec votre
respect à la différence est qu'ici vous
n'aurez pas de haies jester parce que
vous n'avez pas de bluetooth entre votre
smartphone et votre espen pourquoi pas
imaginer faire des deux seins en l'air
pour qu'il se passe des choses pour
déclencher une photo non c'est pas
possible le seul truc que vous avez ici
et bien c'est un petit bouton au centre
qui vous servira pour venir go mais si
vous décidez mais si vous aimez prendre
des notes si vous aimez griffonné si
vous voulez sélectionner du texte très
facilement c'est pour moi un des usages
super intéressant vous trouvez du texte
vous le sélectionner vous pouvez
l'extraire pour le copier et le col et
là vous voulez par exemple mois lors
d'une publication sur instagram si par
exemple je publié une photo d'une vidéo
que j'ai fait pour en faire la promo sur
mon compte instagram et bien je peux
sélectionner la description dans mon
compte youtube je peux le copier je peux
le collet d'instagram bon après je leur
ai adapte bien évidemment ça n'évite
d'abord à tout retaper sa vie de le
faire avec le doigt ou des fois c'est
pas forcément extrêmement évident à ses
traits fins et pratiques de la même
manière pour venir faire de la
traduction très rapidement vous pouvez
griffonné côté un peu de divertissement
pourrait venir dessiner avec bref ce
samsung galaxy z cheval de troie c'est
un grand note c'est un très grand note
pour bénéficier d'un écran qui est
énorme pour venir noté à noter faire
tout ce que vous faisiez avec un hôte et
le faire ont beaucoup plus grand et en
beaucoup plus confortable donc c'est
vraiment tout l'intérêt on avait un
smartphone dédié à la productivité c'est
la gamme galaxy note chez samsung
aujourd'hui on l'a pas peut-être plus
tard je ne suis pas persuadé en tout cas
peut-être plus tard et tout et
transposer ici pour ce samsung galaxy z
folle de 3 alors attention le s pen on
retrouve qu'avec le samsung galaxy z
cheval de troie pas avec un samsung
galaxy cette folle de 2 donc si vous
avez un samsung galaxy cette folle de
deux impossible ça peut être frustrant
c'est vrai mais c'est pas possible est
une application qui est assez sympa
également ses applications penhap peine
open up l'accent n'est pas très bon
pouvait venir apprendre à dessiner vous
pouvez faire plein de trucs très sympa
faire du coloriage ça détend c'est pas
mal petit post on a bien travaillé côté
photo le résultat est vraiment là alors
on aura pas ce qui se fait de mieux chez
samsung mais malgré tout on a quelque
chose qui marche vraiment vraiment
vraiment bien vous regardez là vous
partez sur une photo un peu standard le
hdr est très mais bon ça marche bien les
couleurs sont un peu sur saturé mais bon
voilà c'est très flatteur c'est joli
c'est samsung on peut venir se
rapprocher vous arriver jusqu'à x 10 on
peut pas aller aussi loin qu'on ira avec
un samsung galaxy s 21 ultra mais malgré
tout le résultat est vraiment là et ça
reste très honnête on reste un peu dans
les basques ont avec la gamme note c'est
à dire qu'on va pas avoir les meilleures
photos sur ce smartphone vraiment dédié
à la productivité néanmoins ce qu'il
fait il le fait vraiment bien si vous
voulez ce qui se fait de mieux en terme
de photos aujourd'hui chez samsung il
faut aller sur la gamme s samsung galaxy
s 21 ultra vous aurez le meilleur
résultat mais vous le voyez ici le
résultat est vraiment convenable
vraiment correct ça marche extrêmement
bien sûr toutes les caméras arrière
alors on peut venir à des besoins en
effet plaints des taux dont on peut
regarder bon qui on se bat à clermont
ferrand c'est sympa voyons peu se
rapprocher quand on s'approche trop
salissent c'est normal ça vient corriger
d'un point de vue logiciel mais sinon
dans l'ensemble boulot est vraiment bien
fait et pour toutes vos photos souvenirs
que ce soit sur du grand-angle de l'
ultra grand angle et un zoom jusqu'à x 2
x 5 maximum n'allait pas au delà eh bien
ça ira très bien maintenant la question
se pose par rapport à la caméra que vous
avez à l'intérieur ça c'est typiquement
une photo prise avec la caméra à
l'intérieur
qu'est ce qu'on voit ça vient lycée ça
vient essayer de récupérer d'un point de
vue algorithmique d'un point de vue
logiciel cherche à compenser les
faiblesses mais que sur une caméra de 4
mégapixels qui est là pour mieux capter
plus de luminosité ben oui aujourd'hui
là la recette est pas complètement
fabuleuse et on prend sensiblement le
même cliché avec la caméra celle fille
qui à l'extérieur tout de suite c'est
beaucoup mieux on aura plus de détails
les couleurs sont plus juste autre
exemple cette photo qui est prise une
fois de plus avec la caméra à
l'intérieur il ya quotas peu de ternes
sur les points côté un peu 6 rue un peu
lisse et c'est vraiment pas
extraordinaire et là vous avez la
version avec la caméra de celle fille un
peu standard ça ira très très bien après
ce qui est bien avec ce smartphone là
c'est vous pouvez utiliser n'importe
quel objectif pour faire une photo en
selle fille il vous suffit d'ouvrir
votre smartphone vous avez un smartphone
qui est extrêmement polyvalent pour
toutes les caméras raya grand temps
ultra grand angle zoom mais pas trop on
a ce qu'il faut on peut les utilise
également pour la caméra tu sais le fut
donc c'est un excellent photophone nelsy
ne va pas aussi loin que la gamme
samsung galaxy s2 2021 vous le voyez on
est sur un produit qui est plus sa
destinée professionnelle de par le prix
sa rivale voire professionnels et grand
public tous ceux qui aiment la techno
qui veulent et qui peuvent se le
permettre quasiment 1800 euros ça fait
quand même un petit budget eh bien vous
avez un produit qui est très cool et ce
qui est très rassurant est ce qu a fait
cinq sauts et je trouve vraiment bien ce
qu'ils ont réussi à le faire certifier
ipx8 résistant à l'eau à l'eau douce
bien évident alors tout ce qui va être
poussière et compagnie on n'y est pas
encore on n'est pas sur des
certifications ip68 mais c'est déjà un
vrai paquet effet en avant en plus vous
avez toute une structure qui en
aluminium cl armor aluminium vous avez
un verre corning gorilla glass l'ictus
qui vient davantage le protégé alors ça
reste pas magique bien évidemment mieux
vaut mettre une coque de protection pour
éviter les déconvenues mais c'est vrai
que ce smartphone il ya gagné robustesse
et une fois de plus vu le prix sympa rec
la moindre des choses pour ma part j'ai
vu absolument aucun ralentissement c'est
un smartphone qui marche du feu de dieu
snapdragon 888 il a tout ce qui va bien
à l'intérieur il est rapide performant
pour des sessions de jeu ça marchera
bien pour venir noté ça marche bien
enfin c'est le top du top aujourd'hui
chez samsung et il va plus loin que son
petit frère le samsung galaxy z flip 3
au niveau de la photo soyons clairs
c'est un produit qui est très atypique
il n'est pas fait pour tout le monde
n'est peut-être pas fait pour vous
d'ailleurs dites le moi vous en bas en
commentaire parce que c'est un produit
qui pourrait voter ce que vous avez déjà
le samsung galaxy z folle de 2 ce que
vous aviez acheté le galaxy fold à
l'époque est ce que cette gamme qui se
plie elle vous botte ou pas du tout
c'est un smartphone qui est pas fait
pour tout le monde mais je dirais que
autant d une très très belle évolution
en termes de fabrication on a également
une très belle innovation entre la
caméra sous l'écran autant d'un point de
vue design taille de l'écran n'y a rien
qui change par rapport à l'année
dernière le vrai gros gain qu'on va voir
ici c'est toute la partie productivité
qui n'était pas du tout mise en avant
par samsung qui enfin là est mise en
avant par samsung donc si vous êtes des
amoureux de la productivité si vous
voulez ce qui se fait de mieux
aujourd'hui si vous voulez un super
produit qui est un peu lourd on va pas
se le cacher par rapport à d'autres
smartphones et bien le samsung galaxy
cette folle de troie peut être vraiment
pas mal moi j'utilise depuis plusieurs
jours j'en suis très content jade est
déjà le samsung galaxy cette folle de 2
donc l'usagé du smartphone qui se plie
qui se déplie ça me dérange absolument
pas il ya un truc encore avec ce produit
c'est comme on est sur un produit encore
un peu nichet sur le pliable un produit
le week end relativement cher et bien il
ya des endroits où j'ai un petit peu de
mal à le sortir et à l'ouvrir ce que je
suis un peu par adopte être mais je n'ai
pas envie de me faire remarquer j'ai
peur qu'on me l'arraché donc je fais
toujours attention avec ce smartphone
néanmoins vous le prenez à la main vous
passer un coup de fil comme ça ils
restent très discrets pour les appelle
c'est pareil la qualité est là je fais
communiquer avec ma galaxy ou arcade
classique que j'ai ici dont on pas d'ici
quelques jours j'utilise également avec
des bugs ça marche très très bien la
collection est super bonne bref vous
avez tout ce qu'il faut le meilleur de
samsung à l'intérieur voilà tout ce que
j'avais à vous raconter aujourd'hui sur
ce retour d'expérience produit hyper
complet extrêmement complet on en a plus
que ce qu'on va faire le software est
super bon le hardware est vraiment super
bon ajout d'une espèce c'est vraiment
bien après pour autant si j'avais pas eu
à le tester je sais pas si j'aurais pris
le respect parce que je suis pas
forcément dans la productivité de cette
manière il est endurant il est cool il
est bien et je peux me la péter avec
voilà et je les aime beaucoup a vous de
me dire vous ce que vous en pensez en
bas juste en bas dans les commentaires
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce
smartphone est ce que vous aimez le
pliable ou pas et est ce que vous pensez
que le pliable c'est l'avenir du
smartphone ou alors absolument pas
démarqué en marquant commentaire nous on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
aventures des bisous l'amour pour les
soins du chaos